(big sigh)
- I'm good. Are you good?
(loud laughter)
(drum hit)
- This is our Halloween costume
if we're like, fraternal twins!
This is our ABC Family pilot.
Hi guys!
I'm here with Mitchell Davis!
- Hello!
- If you don't know who Mitchell Davis is,
go straight to hell.
- Makes sense.
- We are going to play
the Newly Friend Game.
And, though Mitchell and
I are not new friends.
- No.
- We've been friends
for how many years now?
- I couldn't tell ya.
- Well, we're gonna do great
at this game (laughter)
I'm so nervous!
- I am nervous.
- There's no losers in this
game, just hurt feelings.
We filmed, or recorded rather,
a full episode of Not Too Deep
and so, after you're
done watching this video,
go over to iTunes or
SoundCold and listen to
that wonderful, wonderful podcast.
But now we're going to get
into the Newly Friends Game.
Jack Ferry, before we started,
asked us five, six questions?
- [Voiceover] Six questions.
- He asked us six different questions
in which we have answered for ourselves
on these pieces of paper
and now we're gonna go
through and try to guess
our new friend's answer.
And the person who
guesses the most correct
truly is the better friend.
- Oh, wow!
Just lay that right on the table.
Fun!
Yes, I like the way you put that.
- You're welcome.
Okay, lets get into
the Newly Friends Game.
- (funny announcer voice)
The Newly Friends Game!
- I knew you were going
to say it like that.
- (very high pitched)
The Newly Friends Game!
- That was a surprise.
There we go.
(laughs)
(orchestra music)
- [Voiceover] The first question:
How did you two meet?
- How did we meet? Do we
show it at the same time?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Wanna count down?
- [Both] Three, Two, One!
- Playlist
- PlaylistLive
(cheer)
- I said plus tequila.
- Oh yeah, there was tequila there.
I did not write that,
but that's only because I don't remember.
- Yeah, we were sitting by the pool
with a bunch of other friends
- yup
and we were drinking
from a bottle of tequila.
- I just remember hearing
that you were at Playlist
and I was like take me to her.
- Same! No that's
literally someone was like,
"Mitchell Davis is coming down"
and we were all sitting
there and I was like
Oh My God, what...
- I was already a little tipsy
- Same!
and I was just like this is gonna be good
this is gonna be a really good beginning.
- It was really fun, but then we also,
I remember in hindsight
we just left all of our gross bottles
and cups by the pool.
- We did.
- We just left it all,
there and all were just like
"whatev blah blah".
- What happens at Playlist
stays at Playlist.
- We got it right!
- We did! and that's one to one.
- We're (symbol crash) friends!
- Yes!!
- [Voiceover] If Mitchell was
stranded on a desert island,
what is the one thing he
couldn't live without?
- What couldn't I live without, Grace?
- What Mitchell couldn't,
I don't think Mitchell could
live without Megabyte, his cat.
- I wrote my cat.
(screams)
I wrote my cat.
- I'm a (symbol clap)
great ass friend! Okay!
- [Voiceover] Mitchell,
if Grace was stranded
on a desert island,
what is the one thing she
couldn't live without?
- Grace, as your friend,
as someone who knows you,
- Okay.
- As someone who feels like they know you
I'm gonna say a nice...
...Shit.
I'm gonna say a nice bottle of...
...oh, some type of liqueur?
Liquor maybe?
I don't know!
Your dog. I don't know. Shit.
Wait no. Scratch all those answers.
New best answer:
You couldn't live without me!
- I wrote "Food (lol but really)"
(laughter)
- That makes more sense.
- I literally could not
live if I did not have food.
- Actually, I need to change my answer
because I might eat my cat.
- Yes.
(laughter)
I have two points.
- Fine, fine. You take it.
- Okay, next question.
- [Voiceover] This is a question
for Grace, about Mitchell.
- What is Mitchell's nickname?
- What's my nickname?
- I personally don't have
a nickname for Mitchell,
but if I had to guess what
Mitchell's nickname is,
I'd say, (laughs) uh...
Ah, I'd say...
...Mitch Mitch.
- (Laughing) Mitch Mitch
- Mhmm. Mitch Mitch.
- No. No.
- [Voiceover] Not the answer.
- Okay, what's the answer?
- The correct answer is Meezy!
(signs) M-EE-Z-Y
- You spelled it wrong
- Oh I spelled it wrong
(laughter)
M-E-E-Z-Y there we go. Meezy.
- Meezy? Who calls you Meezy?
- I do. I've been calling
myself Meezy since '08.
Wassup! There's Yeezy, Jeezy, Keezy,
now there's Meezy.
(laughter)
You know, now there's all kinds of them.
You can call me Meezus if
you're feeling really cool.
- Okay, what's my nickname?
- Uh, what is Grace's nickname?
(laughs)
What is Grace's nickname?
Well, to be fair, I've never
had a nickname for you Grace.
- Yeah.
- But I've always called you...
(laughs)
I always
- a huge (symbol crash)
(laughs)
I mean a nickname that
I've given you kinda
is 'Gracie H in a Box'.
I've just always like, that's
like embedded in my head
as like the nickname.
- Sure, sure.
- Because wasn't that like
your first Youtube name?
- It was my first AOL
Instant Message name.
- Yeah I remember that, so
that's like where my head goes.
- Sure.
Um, yeah I honestly didn't
know what to put for this,
I didn't want to put nothing,
so I just put Rant Accomplice.
- That's good, that's good! Yes!
- I was gonna put something
like Butt Master Butt
- (laughing) Butt Master Butt!
- But, yeah that's good.
We don't have nicknames for each other
- Yeah.
- We're not those kind of friends
- Gracer the Racer I feel
like sounds pretty cool.
Sorry, I'll take that back.
- Maybe think about it for a little bit,
nicknames don't have to be like
(snaps) made up like that.
- Yeah, but I feel like
those are the best ones,
the ones that come right off the cusp.
Okay.
- Quick, what's the first thing...
- Turnip!
- Dang it!
(laughs)
Next question Jack!
- [Voiceover] Besides the United States,
what was the last country Mitchell was in?
- Besides the United States,
what's the last country.
Well, you were supposed to be in the U.K.
in London, in England,
but you had some like
diarrhea happening.
- We don't have to get
that into it, but yeah,
there was definitely a situation
happening in the bathroom.
- Before that, what other
country were you in?
- We've I been? Ooh
Carmen San Diego! Haha!
She travels a lot
(laughs)
- You been in the United States
you've been traveling around.
You were in, I'm going to
say you were in England
because you were in there before
when you were shooting a
bunch of stuff, for Newform.
- Ohhhh! United Kingdom!
- That's upside down, brah!
(cheers)
That counts!
- You got it! You totally got it!
That's the truth.
You are a good friend and I'm the worst.
- [Voiceover] What's the
last country Grace was in,
besides the United States?
- Okay, now Grace I know,
I follow your Instagram,
you were just in this beautiful place.
- Right before the camera turned on,
Mitchell was trying to
make small talk with me,
he just goes, "So you were
away, how was your vacation?"
- I didn't even think...
- And I said, don't try
to get my answers from me!
- [Voiceover] Cheater!
- I know, the inside of me wants to cheat.
I don't know where that was,
I just know that it looked beautiful!
If anything, I'm just going to say
go check out Grace's Instagram,
it looked great, wherever
it was, it looked fantastic!
- My Instagram is it's own country.
- Yeah, it was a place like with hills,
with houses on the hills.
- If you were to guess a country,
you can do it, I have faith in you.
- Oh my.
- Look in my eyes, I'm saying
the answer with my eyeballs.
(giggle)
It's morse code.
- Yeah I know, I just haven't
spoke it in a long time.
Um, you were in...
that was, you were in Italy.
That was Italy.
I don't know.
- You were so close.
- Was I?
- Greece!
- Dang It!
Okay, it looked beautiful,
it was beautiful.
Dang it!
Greece Grace.
- That's my new nickname, Greasy Grace!
- Greasy Grace! There's your nickname.
Turnip and Greasy Grace!
Coming to you live.
- Just two '80's rappers!
- That sounds horrible!
- [Voiceover] If Mitchell won the lottery,
what is the first thing he would buy?
- This is tough.
If you won the lottery, the
first thing you would buy?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
This was hard for me, too.
- I think you would buy your
grandmother a house out here
in Los Angeles with you.
- Aww, that's such a good answer!
I shoulda' wrote that!
(laughs)
- Oh dang it, can I change my answer?
- [Voiceover] What did you write?
- That's what I would write,
but I wrote 'A new iPhone'.
(laughter)
Grandma! I'm so sorry, but it,
the new 6S plus 4k image stabilization.
- That rose gold grandma!
- Wow Grace, you really put me on blast.
- I am sorry, I just think
about thoughtful things.
(laughter)
- Same question for her?
A house in Los Angeles for my grandmother.
(laughter)
You would have an indoor toilet for Goose.
That's what you'd make.
You'd make an indoor toilet for your dog.
- Okay, so just like, a rug?
- No, like an actual, like a tub,
like a bathtub style toilet for a dog.
I'm inventing it, I think, right now.
- Okay.
- An indoor toilet for a dog
is my last answer and final answer, Regis.
- Very close, I said an
apartment in New York City.
- That makes more sense.
That makes a lot more sense.
Dang it! I am really not doing a good job.
- Honestly, that, there's
no way you would know that.
- You know what, I coulda
known, I coulda cheated.
- Oh, well, yup.
I mean, that's the friendship I want.
(laughs)
Okay, this last question I think
should be worth a million points.
- Oh, alright so that means
I can still have a chance to win.
- Yup.
- [Voiceover] What is
Grace's biggest phobia?
- Grace's biggest phobia.
- I was between two answers.
- Now I know, I know this phobia,
only because the first time we ever
filmed something together
I got this phobia out of you on accident.
And we were making a video and
I got really close to you and I said,
"What are you most afraid of Grace?"
and I remember that you
said, "Human touch."
You said human touch, to my face,
so my answer is human touch.
- I wrote claustrophobia,
and then I put claw
because I was, Hermie.
(laughs)
And then I put lol,
because it makes me laugh.
Which I guess is kind of...
- ... Claustrophobia, no, no , no.
That's a different thing,
but I was on the right track.
- Yeah.
- Basically you wanna
live in a suit of armor,
and I knew that.
- No, zero percent, I
would not like to be,
I would love to live in the opposite of...
- Right now, Grace is
saying she wants to be
in a suit of armor at all times.
- I mean, probably like
the opposite of that.
- You heard it hear first,
facts are on the table.
Grace wants a suit of armor.
If you are a suit of armor company...
- Ah, Mitchell's biggest
phobia, I think is....
God, what is Mitchell's biggest phobia?
Mitchell's biggest phobia is...
Shit. What is your biggest phobia?
- I do, I am afraid of a lot of shit.
- You're so afraid of everything.
- I am afraid of a lot of things.
This is actually really great,
because whatever you say,
I'm gonna be like, yeah,
I'm pretty afraid of that.
- Failure.
I kinda might give that to her
'cause my answer was
"Not winning these damn games
on this (symbol crash) show."
So I will give that to you.
(laughter)
- Hashtag livelavalive!
Your self promo.
How dare you!
- Grace, you just won again!
- I don't have you losing.
You create the loss for yourself.
- I know.
- I think you might be afraid of success.
I don't know.
- Oh, okay, I thought we had
discovered something for a minute.
- Who really wins this game?
- No, you did. You did.
- I did, I did. I definitely
won this game big time.
Sorry, I just like, listen and like,
consider you as a human.
(laughter)
- What do you say to
that, Jack? I don't know!
- [Voiceover] Nothing. You just walk out.
- As I wear your merch, I'm
sorry I don't know you more.
- But if you guys wanna get
to know Mitchell even more
than what you've learned here,
then make sure that you go
over to iTunes or SoundCloud
and listen to the full
podcast with he and Jack Ferry
and myself.
We talked a lot about your
transition to Los Angeles.
- Yes.
- We talked a lot about the moon.
- And we talked a lot
about, children's shows,
- Yes!
- And them being incredibly
(symbol crash) up.
- Yes!
- So get all of that over there,
and go check out livelavalive,
Mitchell's channel, livelavalive.tv?
- Yes!
(giggles)
- I like this new, that's a...
- I'm trying to embrace success! Yes!
- I don't know.
There's just no warmth to him.
Speaking of warmth, we're in Los Angeles.
- Yeah!
- Which is...
- [Voiceover] Great segway.
(laughter)
- I've been thinking
about this for minutes.
(drum hit)